tél
[Musique]
mascia nuit et baroin
bonjour à 700 autres fait mon mail
soyez les bienvenus pour regarder quatre
premières votre rendez vous quotidien
consacré au tour de la martinique des
yoles rondes
aujourd'hui avec william on a pris de la
hauteur pour commencer l'émission
nous sommes à mort de gommiers un
quartier qui nous offre une vue
imprenable sur ce que vous voyez
derrière nous la baie du marin
la cinquième étape est partie des anses
d'arlet pour arriver donc juste derrière
nous au marin au programme de votre
magazine
les résultats les analyses de nos
spécialistes et cette ambiance toujours
survolté et on commence tout de suite on
entre dans le vif du sujet un william
voici les résultats de la cour ces coûts
cela
[Musique]
le rocher du diamant le mans marché
panorama exceptionnel pour cette 5e
étape
mais pour les coursiers pas le temps
d'admirer le paysage stratégie et
finances obligatoire sous peine de
sanctions immédiates
un parcours entre les anses d'arlet et
le marin passage obligé entre le rocher
du diamant et la côte puis bruit numéro
un à laisser à tribord au large de
sainte luce avant l'arrivée en
cul-de-sac du marin
dès le départ rosette/orange ufr
champfleury brasserie lorraine sa race
marque laguiole navigue légèrement à
l'écart de la course le vainqueur d'hier
un appétit la panoz à se montre plus
timide pour quitter une zone difficile
il faut beau billet sur y afférent
s'exécute jusqu'à toucher le novembre
rosette orange jouit d'une très légère
avance l'un détenteur du tour sont
toujours en quête d'une première
victoire sur cette édition 2010 8 il en
rêve mais quand la tête des hommes et
dans les nuages
la voile elles se retrouvent à l'eau la
voie est libre pour félix mérine et
diani rémy très rapidement la flotte
s'étire ufr prend la tête et vire de
bord marqué à la culotte par brasserie
lorraine sahara qui fait de même duel
robert marien à la proche du rocher du
diamant
derrière les frères masse navigue plus à
la côte une stratégie qui s'est avérée
payante hier mais pas aujourd'hui
il faut repartir vers le large au pied
du monde larcher brasserie lorraine
sarah a repris la tête et subi une
deuxième attaque de félix mérine la
réponse est immédiate
derrière le dernier jugement reste en
retrait de cette bataille cette fois ci
sur brasserie lorraine sa race et gianni
rémy qui place une attaque et vire de
bord meriem tarder à faire de même
la sanction est immédiate les marlois
reprennent la tête
[Musique]
et tandis que les deux premiers se
battent entre eux les appétits la panoz
à lutte contre les éléments l'eau
s'invite à bord
les coursiers et coop et père de
définitivement de vue les yoles de tête
[Musique]
l'occasion pour cet été mdf de revenir
dans la course ça pas à faire en barque
du poids car il faut des forces pour
s'attaquer aux mapipi un homme ne
suffira pas il en faut un deuxième mais
des conditions de navigation se
complique
[Musique]
c'était des années brasserie lorraine sa
race marg la voile noir tente une
attaque sans succès à bord on réfléchit
à comment tromper la vigilance des yoles
de tête et on perce la concentration
[Musique]
kuhn des contenus qui fait le bonheur de
ike vivant laguiole sans sponsor qui
force l'admiration par ses bons
résultats et sa régularité
l'équipage est troisième
ala bruit brasserie lorraine sarah ufr
champions sont toujours à la lutte
une guerre qui va durer jusqu'à
l'arrivée
sur le vaste plan d'eau du marin
difficile de déterminer avec certitude
la position des gueules en course
une chose est sûre qu'ils allaient me
voudrait bien gagner à domicile un
endroit qu'il connaît par coeur mais
félix mérine n'est pas le premier venu
les deux hommes se surveille mais cette
fois ci les efforts de merine ne
suffiront pas
brasserie lorraine sarah arrive en tête
à domicile
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas fini derrière la lutte fait
rage pour la troisième place hyde au
vent et aux prises avec gf à cotrel
voile orange
mais au milieu des plaisanciers la
navigation est difficile les
embarcations se couche avec qui vont
perdre deux places au profit de gf à
cotrel troisième se marrer petit navire
quatrième le tour 2010 8 reste ouvert
[Musique]
et de deux pour brasserie lorraine
sahara qui s'impose donc à la maison
troisièmes journées sans victoire pour
ufr chanflor 2e à une minute 38 secondes
sur marek petit navire et 3e
réclamations acceptées pour ait souvent
quatrième phase agf à caraïbes qui écope
d'une pénalité de cinq minutes et se
retrouve 5e bonnes performances de tel
brise marine lipton ice tea boucherie
prudent septième en deuxième partie de
classement on retrouve pas moi de demain
pipi à betty l'appaloosa 11e et rosette
orange caraïbe 14e au classement général
ufr conserve donc une fois de plus le
maillot rouge de leader
il va en falloir plus au mari voix de
pascal rain sarah deuxième en huit
minutes 51 secondes pour déstabiliser
félix mérine belle bagarre en
perspective pour la troisième place
occupée par sow marek petit navire mais
attention et douvan quatrième n'est qu'à
22 secondes
gf à caraïbes et 5e la deuxième victoire
consécutive pour rosette orange semble
désormais improbable laguiole est à plus
de deux heures du leader
royal plus de martinique adeptes qui est
distante et tania chaussures termine le
classement
[Musique]
est ce que vous voyez ce qu'il est en
train de se passer
voit ce que l'ol s'est lui fr vous êtes
sûr oui oui à faire jusqu'à poitiers
ballan et affaires et par là alors là de
la gold légales sont pas encore passés
vous faites sur ces affaires
[Applaudissements]
bitar de brasserie lorraine à domicile
c'est la folie si c'est le fun c'est
l'ambiance de carnaval
vous êtes euros couple est comblé lorsqu
il y à de telles joies
on dit merci au bon dieu et puis bon on
salue les autres franchisés
validez deuxième aujourd'hui bravo les
fermiers n auront plus à faire
à
voilà comme à son habitude mangata de la
peur
avec l'autre sur la tête regardez
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allah
[Applaudissements]
alors vous vous êtes messieurs messia
louis mk oui oui d'abidjan on aime ça
fait du bien ça fait rire ça me fait du
bien
la deuxième mon aïeul on a gardé notre
maillot mais voyons la victoire finale
oui pourquoi à chaque fois je vois je
crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois ils ont fait preuve de
force
vous êtes de vrais bonhomme c'était dur
témoin c'était dur
[Musique]
du coup comme en vue du lion mais
partiellement did you puisque le vent
qu'on attendait vraiment vous à l'époque
les deux si nos guides et le vent ils
avaient tous mais plus je vois que les
gens profitent y ait la volonté qu'on a
fait c'est très bien mais je voulais
vous poser de questions vous avez dit
que vous voyez que nous sommes des
frères
comme vous le voyez je voulais dire que
de véritables athlètes pour moi vous
êtes des athlètes de très haut niveau
ce que vous faites tout le monde ne peut
pas le faire avoir le sens de la mer
avoir tout d'abord l'équilibré l'esprit
d'équipé merci et bravo voilà ce que je
voulais dire gaza a été difficile en
bien de l'entendre mais on va écouter
les détails de cette étape avec les
paroles des patrons eux mêmes ces
paroles mapipi on avait à coeur de
reprendre et à le rénover deuxième cette
année au regard du bavardage au but
il était jugé bienvenu alvarez qui a
fait la différence aujourd'hui
stratégiquement part n'entend pas s'en
plaindre qu'on connaissait donc on
attendait qu'on savait qu'on affrontait
on a fait le boulot d'un voile puisque
je pense qu'on avait ouverte après car
en plus qu'à lui menace qui fait la
différence entre l'arrêt de la sagesse
et voilà nous tant mieux ça nous dit et
fait mieux que ma pelouse répondra c'est
nous mais demain nous reste des métiers
et les pendules à l'heure parce que je
me laisse aller l'as dragons de saint
clar diaw noah on va voir beaucoup de
choses au rouge aux hommes en noir
c'est une superbe étape mais comme on
joue alors c'était une étape quand même
qui s'est relativement bien passé pour
vous vous étiez au coude à coude avec jf
a échappé long oui on a dû en tout la
banque où on était au coude à coude avec
eux on a su gérer la bataille et là il a
voulu faire sont mal élevés nous
empêcher de passer
sauf une belle bataille depuis le début
du tout en courant après un podium
aujourd'hui on fait une très très belle
journée je félicite tous ces gamins
il faut pas oublier le premier tour et
ils ont très très bien bossé pense que
c'est l'avenir demain ils vont
progressivement tout cas projet f1 c'est
une très belle journée
[Musique]
joe williams pendant toute la semaine du
tour des yoles l'île de la martinique
est en fête
gerty gare le tour puisqu'un événement
sportif permet de rassembler les
familles de se restaurer et de s'amuser
exactement les villes de départ et
l'éviter arrivée met en place une grosse
infrastructure pour pouvoir accueillir
tous les supporters c'est notre séquence
en bataille du jour les coulisses du
tour
[Musique]
le programme c'est quoi comme on peut
déjà on boit on mange ce qu'on attend
l'arrivée des yoles et l'achat
je vois des amis on m'annonce mais on
mène à la mairie à mes côtés ça fait une
visibilité on va dire pour le commerce
c'est bien parce que la visibilité elle
elle est contre il ya de nouveaux
clients perspectives et des choses comme
ça comme ça très toros sont fait
connaître dans sa commune natale
notre succès c'est la fricassée de
l'ambient je n'ai jamais vu ça un petit
fricassée de l'ambient à ma femme est en
vacances ici je les rejoins et et puis
là j'en profite pour des yoles aussi ça
fait partie du folklore on est là aussi
pour ça
j'attends l'arrivée d'embrasser leur
aide quand même temps j'écoute la
musique qu'ils soient en haut des temps
et nathan
[Musique]
un événement incontournable c'est ta
population qu'ils visitent
toutes les arrivées d'étapes donc c'est
l'opportunité pour de capter ce public
et puis de pouvoir diffuser
l'information au plus grand nombre
nous avons un centre de formation
national
on a toujours souhaité être dans les
antilles françaises donc on est ici pour
se faire connaître pour satisfaire les
martiniquais et ça a fait plaisir pour
nous on se fait plaisir ou plutôt plus
aux yeux de jeune femme débuts voilà en
attendant l'école on peut boire un coup
on peut aller manger quelque part
il prévoit de l'argent justement pour
pouvoir consommer des glaces des sous le
pôle à manger de tout être un stand
c'est différent face au froid plus de
monde
on se dit les jambes à la gueule mais on
se dit jamais commencé de l'autre côté
[Musique]
avec tous les éléments que nous avons
ici on représente déjà la fédération
générale par beaucoup d'éléments dans la
boutique maison de façon que les gens
puissent connaissent vraiment lier les
vacanciers quand il pleut touchant me
disent de mer ça je vais le mettre dans
l'avion comme ça on me dira church
sociale ou arrivée à paris dans le métro
il a encore faire beau je vais profiter
au moins pour leur dire que j'ai fait
cette année
[Musique]
ça fait boitiller à la marina du marin
c'est l'une des plus grandes de médecine
antique là qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
qu'est ce qu'on est bien là williams à
la cool et relax c'est pas la même
histoire pour les équipages pendant la
course et non l'a vu hier déjà pour les
équipages et notamment pour ufr chanflor
ça a été très difficile pour les
organismes
je suis sûr que vous avez envie de
revivre ce moment exactement alors on
propose les images de nos caméras
embarquées au coeur de la yole c'est en
trio là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin entendre de chair on n'était pas
en tête on est ravi et la première bouée
navire la première bouée à 5 6e position
mais la descente nous a favorisés
on avait quand même un peu plus de voir
que les autres on les a dépassés à lille
et amiens et après on a pris la tête de
la côte jusqu'à 9 heures après en
arrivant ils sont las du faux le vent
n'a pas été favorable aux ils ont ils
ont vraiment coller la terre puisque
nous c'est plutôt intéressant pour eux
avouent lebron de risque vraiment de
concerts en quoi nos coachs cafal des
ventes et on voulait pas de raison du
bond du vendeur
et puis convives on va on est à la boue
directement à ses goûts et les appétits
à déjouer ils sont allés chercher le
vent à terre et c'est formidable
c'était certainement à faire
[Musique]
ça
regard de william hill ont perdu quelque
chose dans l'eau c'est une pagaie tiga
et en fait c'est un élément essentiel
pour diriger l'embarcation est ce que ce
n'est pas de la pagaie qu'on va parler
aujourd'hui dans le technique yole tout
à fait tous les jours décrypte un des
éléments de laguiole voici la bague
[Musique]
la baguette est en bois massif
renforcé par de la fibre de verre ou de
carbone et de l'art et si elle mesure de
trois mètres 84 m
la pagaie pèse 35 à 40 kg les pagaies
sont de formes et de tailles différentes
elle est plus ou moins large et plus ou
moins arrondir son extrémité
pour godiller il faut une pagaie plus
courte et plus légère pour garder un
effort plus constant à l'arrière de la
coque à tribord et à bâbord sont montés
les engrenages
il cerne à calais la pagaie
sa durée de vie est de trois à cinq ans
quand elle est abîmée certaines équipes
changent juste le manche car elle goûte
tout de même jusqu'à 2500 euros sa
fonction est de diriger et man uvrer
embarcations la pagaie permet de tenir
le cas mais en cas de pétole c'est à
dire en l'absence de vent la pagaie
permet également de godille pour un
cancer
dans ce cas les équipages adopte souvent
une pagaie plus petites et plus légères
pour plus d'efficacité tenir la baguette
est aux postes stratégiques
c'est le rôle de patron et des patrons
[Musique]
m
elle est maintenant le préfet thomas
mais alors d'où viennent toutes ses
langoustes et ses craintes de mer à côté
de lui les cas ben oui c'est une telle
échelle c'est une pêche pour c'est
minime ça oui la paroisse la presse
combien c'est la jetée du 4e au parquet
d'auxerre
waouh ça fait combien de temps que tu
pêches de pêcheurs spécialiste de la
pêche mais aussi on a notre expert
maison c'est jean trudeau est d'ailleurs
place à son analyse de l'étape du jour
et il va nous dire ce qui attend les
coursiers demain c'est d'opter yonne
[Musique]
mon petit doigt m'avait dit que gianni
rémy et georges henri la girouette
mettez à mener cette huile ou marié en
premier mais mon petit doigt ne l'avait
pas dit que vous êtes orange prendrait
la tête dès le départ
coucou les petits moments après et puis
une heure après notre mapipi disparaît
de la carte
j'apprécie la balle aux uns prennent la
tête de lionne une yole avec une voile
de 50 m² et une autre avec une voile de
40 mètres carrés
donc il ya quand même une différence y
on sait que c'est du viol marche très
bien auprès avec une ambition d'arriver
aux marins en tête mais pendant tout le
parcours on oublie un peu les autres
parce que vraiment le voir tout ça a été
un mano à mano entre ces deux viols des
bords à l'intérieur dès lors à
l'extérieur ça a été difficile jusque
dans la zac du marin où seront du sud ou
repasser aux teneurs des faisans quoi
vous pouvez voir le filet mais non on
arrive au plus près en tirant des bombes
une minute et quelques défenses pour le
premier sur le second à domicile même
pas encore les données on descend
aujourd'hui en a fait un art les marins
demain on fait marc installé dès le
départ les voiles son fils et on descend
dès son arrivée à la pointe borgne
souvent en panne et les enfants n'a été
dépassée tout le temps des contrôles
pour arriver dans ce que l'on redoute
tout simplement le passage entre la
terre entre autres le rocher du diamant
et la terre
le passage des fous et puis arrivé sous
le monde jacqueline à côté de la
chaudière cette fameuse arrivée que
seule la ville d'installer peut nous
réserver un bord à bord ou mano à mano
combat sans fin en toile est dur donc
mon petit doigt me dit rien vous donner
[Musique]
siga place à notre rubrique à plat tout
c'est la rubrique du magazine n'y a pas
d'histoire cap à cap je saute à l'eau en
tout cas pratiques chute au delà
aujourd'hui je ne sauterai palou
d'accord demain de la 6e étape les
courtiers vont pas te bis de la plage du
marin et seront attendus aux anses
d'arlet voici tout de suite le profil de
l'étape cap la 6e étape
marc est installé départ à 10 heures de
la plage du bourg du marel voile filet
direction la pointe des zones empannage
de voile à la pointe bord et niaise pour
aller en direction de la marque numéro
un qui est situé face à l'inspiron il
faut passer entre la marque numéro un la
terre là les voiles son fils et si le
vin et haisnes horde est dominant on est
au vent arrière avec beaucoup de
manoeuvres beaucoup de stabilité de
laguiole à établir direction cette
fameuse pointe de diamant pour la
laisser sur tribord passé entre la terre
et le rocher du diamant aborder nos
habituels difficulté du côté de la fasse
défaut du côté du monde jacqueline ses
rafales qui viennent de la terre qui
viennent de petites installer
désinstaller
enfin aussi abordé les rafales qui
viennent de l'anchois d'hyères pour
aller virer cette marque numéro 2 a
laissé sur tribord où aller couper la
ligne d'arrivée constitué de deux bouées
mouillées devant la plage du bourg
désinstalle
[Musique]
toute l'équipe de quatre premières se
joint à nous pouvons remercier
infiniment pour votre fidélité
nous allons vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous suivre tous les jours et
ça nous fait chaud au coeur et merci à
vous supporters d'être de plus en plus
nombreux à l'arrivée les courtiers ont
besoin de vous pour aller au bout d'eux
mêmes
on vous attend nombreux à l'arrivée
demain aux anses d'arlet retrouvez votre
magazine la quotidien sur martinique
1ère tous les jours donc à 20 heures et
à 16 heures 35 pour les matinaux sur
facebook
bein moi à demain je n'irai pas aboli ou
alterné ces salaires sont dus mais
depuis tout petit
[Musique]
il